I just had to turn the camera back on for this, which is the wet zone.
How'd they know that I was gonna show up?
[laughs] kay...
-Time Lapse With Music Vloggers Use-
Is it- it's working?
Good framing?
Bob: It is actually.
Mark: [uncertain] Yeah? Really?
Huh. That's shocking.
Uhm..
We're walking to the zoo?
Is that important to say?
Are we gonna find out about this?
Bob: You know as much about this as I do.
Mark:  Yeah, probably.
Bob: Most of my-my vlogs just turn out to be jokes.
Mark: Yeah.
And I-I look really stupid-
I'm channeling a Casey Neistat right now
Uh..
With the gorilla tripod,
and holding it out in front of me..
..And looking like an idiot talking to myself.
Bob: Yeah.
Mark: So.. Not that he's an idiot
I'm not trying to insult him in anyway,
I'm just saying when I do it,
I look stupid.
Time for the time lapse.
Bob: Yeah, like six time lapses.
Mark: [laughs]
[music]
Mark:  What is that?
Bob:  As leader, I declare that we're going this way.
Mark: Ok, Vlog leader.
Vlog leader, please.
[laughter]
Vlog leader, your antics are definitely going to get me more views.
But..
-later.
My 4'9 arms are..
Very small.
My-My arms themselves aren't 4'9.
I'm saying I'm 4'9.
And my arms are proportional to that height.
[Mark sighs]
Brother fist~ [kissing sound]
Top o' the mornin' to you laddies.
Bob: [in the background] I- That's- Those are the same person.
Mark: Wait, you're saying Pewdiepie and Jacksepticeye are the same person?
Bob: Oh jesus.
[both men laugh, along with the rest of the crew]
Mandy: It's become a battle.
Mark: Top o' the fist to you laddies.
Bob: Well there's the thumbnail right there.
Mark: Right there?
Bob: Pewdiepie and Jacksepticeye are the same person.
M: Just put them both in the thumbnail.
B: --Mark's face in the thumbnail.
Mark: (quietly)  Top o' the mornin' to ya laddies...my name is jackse--
Mark:  *laughing*  Don't film me doin' this!
[everyone laughing]
Bob: I wanna film the evolution of Mark figuring out.
Mark: *laughs* How the-- how the shot's gonna be.
Mark:  Top o' the mornin' to you laddies!
I'm gonna- Goodbye. *Mark laughing, others join in*
Bob: I'm getting Mark on camera--  *laughing*
Mark: SHUT UP
Bob:  Your stomps are gonna be on the microphone.
Mark:  People will know just by my emotions.
SHHHHHHHHH.
Mark:  Alright, you take this.
Bob: Fine, yeah.
Mark: Alright, okay. Ready? A'ight.
*grunts*
Mark:  Alright, cut-cut it.
(Bob: Just Mark's tombstone.)
[laughter]
Mark:  Damn, she thicc
Mark:  Oh wow! *laughing*
Bob: He's trying to drown the other turtle-
Mark:  He just wants us all to watch-
Watch as he murders this other turtle.
Bob: We're here for a show--
Mark: *laughs* That other turtle's, like, I approoooove.
OH MY GOD *laughing*
He stepped on his head!
Oh no....
Now I feel bad..
We were joking, but I think this is really happening!
Oh-Oh! Free him! Free him!
Alright, so I just dropped my mic.
Um.. This is more of a test to see if it's still working..
Uh.. Yeah?
Eric]: Yeah!
Mark:  Probably.
Yeah, so we're leaving the zoo and we're gonna go -uh elsewhere.
Mark: Uh, 'cause we're in DC and -uhm..
(Bob: We're gonna go to the people zoo.)
Yeah, we're gonna look at people,
-and, mostly people have just been looking at me, oddly enough, I don't know why.
I'm just doing a lot of this.
Bob: Just do a lotta that up on the toes..
Mark: I'M CASEY NEISTAT.
[camera hits leaves]
Mark:  SHIT
[everyone laughs]
-A TIME LAPSE YET AGAIN-
Bob:  Well, now you're just super backlit.
Mark:  Dat... good enough for me.
It's all I need. I don't need to be lit.
I'm already lit enough as it is.
[badass music]
Mark: I dunno... I'm not clever enough to insult you on the fly.
[airplane flying overhead]
Mark: Is that a good plane sound?
Bob: Picking up that airplane good?
Mark: Lil' bit.
Mark:  That's nice.
Mark: Okay, so Bob--
Bob: --That's the kind of thing.
Mark: Hush! HUSH! HUSSH!
Mark: Bob just told me that it's magic hour--
Bob: Sorry I'll be quiet, Mark. Sorry.
Mark: Bob just told me that it's--
Bob: I'm sorry!
[Eric & Mandy laughing]
Bob: What, I'm just saying that I'm sorry and I'll be quiet now.
Mark: Bob just told me that it's magic hour right now, and uh, this is when lighting looks the best.
So, I just turned on my camera so that people could know this fact.
Bob: I'm not doing that!
[Bob, Mandy & Eric laugh]
Mark:  What did you do??
(Bob: How long do you think my arms are?)
Bob: I mean you didn't do anything, shut up.
Mark:  Wh- I Wasn't talking!
Bob: Then shut up! Good!
Mark:  Okay..?
These are my friends.
Alright, we've been walking quite a while
we're all starting to get tired and sweaty and gross...
Uh...
Bob: You're gross.
Mark: There's a lot of fluids building up all over the place.
Um..
And, uh, eventually, we'll get back home... just not yet.
Bob: That's what Mark thinks.
Mark: Oh.
[Mandy laughs]
Mark:  Am I never going home?
Bob: Actually...
That thing I said earlier about you already being dead, that's true.
Mark: Oh! Nice, cool.
Well, I'm dead.
So, sorry guys.
(Bob: It'll resolve soon, don't worry.)
Mark: Okay...
As always, I'll see you in the next life, buh-bye...
Bob: -snickers-
Bob: Th-That's how you go out? -imitates- buh-bye.
*laughs*
Mark: My last words.
(dying voice) Buh-bye...
Mark: This um uh...
Bob: Good- good DC trip?
Mark: Good.
Bob: Thumbs up?  Mark: Thumbs up.
Mark: Let's go home then uh, get some food and then...
Not-Not worry about being all sweaty.
Bob: Let me get the same shot-- here, I'll film your screen--
Oh, it's covered, nevermind.
Bob: Get that same shot.
Mark: Nice.
Bob: Yeah
Bob: I'm gonna get copyright claimed.
Mark: Yeah!
Bob: Yeah!
Okay, so I didn't like the last goodbye, so I'm gonna do another goodbye. Um...
Bob: *chants* Dick, dick, dick
The guys: Dick, dick, dick, dick, dick, dick, dick, dick, dick, dick, dick, dick, dick-
Okay, bye.
Bob: Wow, that was so much better.
Mark: *laughs*